This is a Galton Board. Maybe you've seen
one before. It's a popular demonstration
of how even when a single event is chaotic and
random, with an effectively unknowable outcome,
it's still possible to make precise
statements about a large number of events,
namely how the relative proportions for
many different outcomes are distributed.
More specifically, the Galton board
illustrates one of the most prominent
distributions in all of probability,
known as the Normal distribution,
more colloquially known as a Bell curve, and
also called a Gaussian distribution. There's
a very specific function to describe this
distribution. Very pretty. We'll get into
it later, but right now, I just want to
emphasize how the normal distribution is,
as the name suggests, very common. It shows
up in a lot of seemingly unrelated contexts.
If you were to take a large number of people
who sit in a similar demographic and plot their
heights, those heights tend to follow a normal
distribution. If you look at a large swath of
very big natural numbers and you ask how many
distinct prime factors does each one of those
numbers have, the answers will very closely
track with a certain normal distribution.
Now, our topic for today is one of the crown
jewels in all of probability theory. It's
one of the key facts that explains why
this distribution is as common as it is,
known as the Central Limit Theorem. This
lesson is meant to go back to the basics,
giving you the fundamentals on what
the Central Limit Theorem is saying,
what normal distributions are, and
I want to assume minimal background.
We're going to go decently deep into it, but
after this, I'd still like to go deeper and
explain why the theorem is true, why the function
underlying the normal distribution has the very
specific form that it does, why that formula has
a pi in it, and, most fun, why those last two
facts are actually more related than a lot
of traditional explanations would suggest.
That second lesson is also meant to be the follow
on to the convolutions video that I promised. So,
there's a lot of interrelated topics here.
But right now, back to the fundamentals. I'd
like to kick things off with an overly
simplified model of the Galton board.
In this model, we will assume that each
ball falls directly onto a certain central
peg and then it has a 50 - 50 probability
of bouncing to the left or to the right,
and we'll think of each of those outcomes as
either adding one or subtracting one from its
position. Once one of those is chosen, we
make the highly unrealistic assumption that
it happens to land dead on in the middle
of the peg adjacent below it, where again,
it'll be faced with the same 50 - 50 choice
of bouncing to the left or to the right.
For the one I'm showing on screen, there are
five different rows of pegs. So our little
hopping ball makes five different
random choices between plus one and
minus one and we can think of its final
position as basically being the sum of
all of those different numbers. Which in
this case happens to be one and we might
label all of the different buckets
with the sum that they represent.
As we repeat this, we're looking at different
possible sums for those five random numbers.
And for those of you who are inclined to complain
that this is a highly unrealistic model for the
true Galton board, let me emphasize - the goal
right now is not to accurately model physics,
the goal is to give a simple example to
illustrate the central limit theorem,
and for that, idealized though this might be,
it actually gives us a really good example.
If we let many different balls fall, making
yet another unrealistic assumption that they
don't influence each other, as if they're all
ghosts, then the number of balls that fall into
each different bucket gives us some loose sense
for how likely each one of those buckets is.
In this example the numbers are simple
enough that it's not too hard to explicitly
calculate what the probability is for
falling into each bucket. If you do
want to think that through, you'll find
it very reminiscent of Pascal's triangle,
but the neat thing about our theorem is
how far it goes beyond the simple examples.
So, to start off at least, rather than making
explicit calculations, let's just simulate
things by running a large number of samples
and letting the total number of results in
each different outcome give us some sense for
what that distribution looks like. As I said,
the one on screen has five rows, so each sum that
we're considering includes only five numbers.
The basic idea of the central limit theorem
is that if you increase the size of that sum,
for example, here that would mean
increasing the number of rows of
pegs for each ball to bounce off, then
the distribution that describes where
that sum is going to fall looks
more and more like a bell curve.
Here, it's actually worth taking a
moment to write down that general idea.
The setup is that we have a random variable
and that's basically shorthand for a random
process where each outcome of that process is
associated with some number. We'll call that
random number X. For example, each bounce off
the peg is a random process modeled with two
outcomes. Those outcomes are associated with
the numbers negative one and positive one.
Another example of a random variable would be
rolling a die, where you have six different
outcomes each one associated with a number. What
we're doing is taking multiple different samples
of that variable and adding them all together.
On our Galton board, that looks like letting the
ball bounce off multiple different pegs on
its way down to the bottom, and in the case
of a die, you might imagine rolling many
different dice and adding up the results.
The claim of the central limit theorem is that
as you let the size of that sum get bigger and
bigger, then the distribution of that sum, how
likely it is to fall into different possible
values, will look more and more like a bell
curve. That's it, that is the general idea.
Over the course of this lesson, our job is to
make that statement more quantitative. We're going
to put some numbers to it, put some formulas to
it, show how you can use it to make predictions.
For example, here's the kind of question I want
you to be able to answer by the end of this video;
suppose you roll the die 100 times,
and you added together the results.
Could you find a range of values such that you're
95% sure that the sum will fall within that
range. Or maybe I should say, find the smallest
possible range of values such that this is true.
The neat thing is, you'll be able to answer
this question whether it's a fair die or if
it's a weighted die. Now, let me say at the
top that this theorem has three different
assumptions that go into it. Three things
that have to be true before the theorem
follows and I'm actually not going to tell you
what they are until the very end of the video.
Instead, I want you to keep your eye out and
see if you can notice and maybe predict what
those three assumptions are going to be. As a
next step to better illustrate just how general
this theorem is, I want to run a couple more
simulations for you focused on the dice example.
Usually, if you think of rolling a die, you think
of the six outcomes as being equally probable, but
the theorem actually doesn't care about that. We
could start with a weighted die - something with
a non-trivial distribution across the outcomes and
the core idea still holds, for the simulation what
will do is take some distribution, like this one
that is skewed towards lower values. I'm going to
take 10 distinct samples from that distribution,
and then I'll record the sum of that sample on
the plot, on the bottom. Then I'm going to do
this many many different times. Always with the
sum of size 10 but keep track of where those sums
ended up to give us a sense of the distribution.
And in fact, let me rescale the y direction to
give us room to run an even larger number of
samples, and I'll let it go all the way
up to a couple thousand and as it does,
you'll notice that the shape that
starts to emerge looks like a bell
curve. Maybe if you squint your eyes you
can see it skews a tiny bit to the left,
but it's neat that something so symmetric emerged
from a starting point that was so asymmetric.
To better illustrate what the central limit
theorem is all about, let me run four of these
simulations in parallel. Where on the upper
left I'm doing it - we're only adding two dice
at a time. On the upper right, we're doing
it where we're adding five dice at a time,
the lower left is the one that we
just saw, adding 10 dice at a time
and then we'll do another one
with a bigger sum, 15 at a time.
Notice how on the upper left when we're just
adding two dice, the resulting distribution
doesn't really look like a bell curve, it
looks a lot more reminiscent of the one we
started with - skewed towards the left. But as
we allow for more and more dice in each sum,
the resulting shape that comes up in these
distributions looks more and more symmetric.
It has the lump in the middle and fade
towards the tail shape of a bell curve.
Let me emphasize again, you can start with any
different distribution. Here I'll run it again
but where most of the probability is tied up in
the numbers 1 and 6 with very low probability for
the mid values. Despite completely changing the
distribution for an individual roll of the die,
it's still the case that a bell curve shape
will emerge as we consider the different sums.
Illustrating things with a simulation like
this is very fun and it's kind of neat to
see order emerge from chaos, but it also feels
a little imprecise. Like in this case. When I
cut off the simulation at 3000 samples, even
though it kind of looks like a bell curve,
the different buckets seem pretty spiky? And you
might wonder is it supposed to look that way or
is that just an artifact of the randomness in the
simulation, and if it is, how many samples do we
need before we can be sure that what we're looking
at is representative of the true distribution?
Instead moving forward, let's get a little more
theoretical and show the precise shape that these
distributions will take on in the long run. The
easiest case to make this calculation is if we
have a uniform distribution, where each possible
face of the die has an equal probability, 1/6.
For example, if you then want to know how
likely different sums are for a pair of dice,
it's essentially a counting
game where you count up how
many distinct pairs take on the same
sum. Which in the diagram I've drawn,
you can conveniently think about by going
through all of the different diagonals.
Since each such pair has an equal
chance of showing up, 1 in 36,
all you have to do is count the sizes of
these buckets. That gives us a definitive
shape for the distribution describing a
sum of two dice and if we were to play
the same game with all possible triplets, the
resulting distribution would look like this.
Now, what's more challenging but a lot more
interesting is to ask what happens if we have
a non-uniform distribution for that single die.
We actually talked all about this in the last
video. You do essentially the same thing, you go
through all the distinct pairs of dice which add
up to the same value. It's just that instead of
counting those pairs, for each pair, you multiply
the two probabilities of each particular face
coming up and then you add all those together.
The computation that does this for
all possible sums has a fancy name,
it's called a Convolution but it's essentially
just the weighted version of the counting game
that anyone who's played with a pair of dice
already finds familiar. For our purposes,
in this lesson, I'll have the computer calculate
all that, simply display the results for you
and invite you to observe certain patterns,
but under the hood, this is what's going on.
So, just to be crystal clear on
what's being represented here,
if you imagine sampling two different
values from that top distribution,
the one describing a single die and adding
them together, then the second distribution
I'm drawing represents how likely you
are to see various different sums.
Likewise, if you imagine sampling three distinct
values from that top distribution and adding
them together, the next plot represents the
probabilities for various different sums in that
case. So, if I compute what the distributions for
these sums look like for larger and larger sums,
well, you know what I'm going to say, it
looks more and more like a bell curve.
But before we get to that, I want you to
make a couple more simple observations.
For example, these distributions
seem to be wandering to the right,
and also they seem to be getting more
spread out and a little bit more flat.
You cannot describe the central limit
theorem quantitatively without taking
into account both of those effects, which
in turn requires describing the mean and the
standard deviation. Maybe you're already
familiar with those, but I want to make
minimal assumptions here and it never hurts to
review. So let's quickly go over both of those.
The mean of a distribution, often
denoted with a Greek letter, mu,
is a way of capturing the center of mass for that
distribution. It's calculated as the expected.
Value of our random variable, which is a
way of saying you go through all of the
different possible outcomes and you multiply
the probability of that outcome times the
value of the variable. If higher values are more
probable, that weighted sum is going to be bigger,
if lower values are more probable, that
weighted time is going to be smaller.
A little more interesting is if you want to
measure how spread out this distribution is,
because there's multiple
different ways you might do it.
One of them is called the Variance. The idea
there is to look at the difference between
each possible value and the mean, square
that difference and ask for its expected
value. The idea is that whether your value is
below or above the mean, when you square that
difference you get a positive number and the
larger the difference, the bigger that number.
Squaring it like this turns out to make the math
much, much nicer than if we did something like
an absolute value, but the downside is that
it's hard to think about this as a distance
in our diagram because the units are off. Kind
of like the units here are square units whereas
a distance in our diagram would be a kind
of linear unit. So, another way to measure
spread is what's called the Standard Deviation,
which is the square root of this value. That can
be interpreted much more reasonably as a distance
on our diagram and it's commonly denoted with the
Greek letter Sigma. So, you know M for mean,
as for standard deviation but both in Greek.
Looking back at our sequence of
distributions, let's talk about
the mean and standard deviation. If we call
the mean of the initial distribution mu,
which for the one Illustrated happens to be
2.24, hopefully, it won't be too surprising if
I tell you that the mean of the next one is two
times mu. That is, you roll a pair of dice, you
want to know the expected value of the sum, it's
two times the expected value for a single die.
Similarly, the expected value for
our sum of size 3 is 3 times mu and
so on and so forth. The mean just
marches steadily on to the right,
which is why our distributions seem to be
drifting off in that direction. A little
more challenging but very important is to
describe how the standard deviation changes.
The key fact here is that if you
have two different random variables,
then the variance for the sum of those variables
is the same as just adding together the original
two variances. This is one of those facts that
you can just compute when you unpack all the
definitions. There are a couple nice intuitions
for why it's true. My tentative plan is to just
actually make a series about probability
and talk about things like intuition's
underlying variants and its cousins there,
but right now, the main thing I want you to
highlight is how it's the variance that adds,
it's not the standard deviation that adds.
So critically, if you were to take
'n' different realizations of the
same random variable and ask what the sum
looks like, the variance of that sum is
'n' times the variance of your original
variable, meaning the standard deviation,
the square root of all this, is the square root
of n times the original standard deviation.
For example, back in our sequence
of distributions, if we label the
standard deviation of our initial one with
Sigma, then the next standard deviation is
going to be the square root of 2 times Sigma,
and after that, it looks like the square root
of 3 times Sigma and so on and so forth. This
like I said is very important. It means that
even though our distributions are getting
spread out, they're not spreading out all
that quickly. They only do so in proportion
to the square root of the size of the sum.
As we prepare to make a more quantitative
description of the central limit theorem,
the core intuition I want you to keep in your
head is that we'll basically realign all of
these distributions so that their means line up
together and then rescale them so that all of the
standard deviations are just going to be equal to
one. And when we do that, the shape that results
gets closer and closer to a certain universal
shape described with an elegant little function
that will unpack in just a moment. And let me say
one more time, the real magic here is how we could
have started with any distribution describing a
single roll of the die and if we play the same
game, considering what the distributions for the
many different sums look like and we realign them
so that the means line up and we rescale them
so that the standard deviations are all one,
we still approach that same universal
shape which is kind of mind-boggling.
And now my friends is probably as good a time
as any to finally get into the formula for a
normal distribution. And the way I'd like
to do this is to basically peel back all
the layers and build it up one piece at a
time. The function eˣ or anything to the
X describes exponential growth. And
if you make that exponent negative,
which flips around the graph horizontally, you
might think of it as describing exponential decay.
To make this decay in both directions,
you could do something to make sure the
exponent is always negative and growing,
like taking the negative absolute value,
that would give us this kind of awkward sharp
point in the middle, but if instead you make
that exponent the negative square of X, you
get a smoother version of the same thing,
which decays in both directions. This
gives us the basic bell curve shape.
Now, if you throw a constant in front of that X
and you scale that constant up and down, it lets
you stretch and squish the graph horizontally
allowing you to describe narrow and wider bell
curves. And a quick thing I'd like to point out
here is that based on the rules of exponentiation,
as we tweak around that constant C, you could also
think about it as simply changing the base of the
exponentiation. And in that sense, the number e
is not really all that special for our formula. We
could replace it with any other positive constant
and you'll get the same family of curves as we
tweak that constant. Make it a two, same family
of curves, make it a three, same family of curves.
The reason we use e is that it gives that
constant a very readable meaning, or rather
if we reconfigure things a little bit so that the
exponent looks like negative 1/2 times x divided
by a certain constant which we'll suggestively
call Sigma squared, then once we turn this into a
probability distribution, that constant Sigma will
be the standard deviation of that distribution,
and that's very nice. But before we can interpret
this as a probability distribution, we need the
area under the curve to be one. And the reason
for that is how the curve is interpreted.
Unlike discrete distributions, when
it comes to something continuous,
you don't ask about the probability of
a particular point. Instead, you ask for
the probability that a value falls between
two different values. And what the curve is
telling you is that that probability equals the
area under the curve between those two values.
There's a whole other video about
this. They're called probability
density functions. The main point right now is
the area under the entire curve represents the
probability that something happens, that
some number comes up. That should be one,
which is why we want the
area under this to be one.
As it stands with the basic bell curve shape of
e to the negative x squared, the area is not one,
it's actually the square root of pi. I know,
right? What is pi doing here? What does this have
to do with circles? Like I said at the start, I'd
love to talk all about that in the next video but
if you can spare your excitement for our purposes
right now, all it means is that we should divide
this function by the square root of Pi and it
gives us the area we want. Throwing back in the
constants we had earlier, the 1/2 and the sigma,
the effect there is to stretch out the graph by
a factor of Sigma times the square root of two.
So, we also need to divide out by that in order
to make sure it has an area of one, and combining
those fractions, the factor out front looks like
1 divided by Sigma times the square root of 2 pi.
This finally is a valid probability distribution.
As we tweak that value Sigma,
resulting in narrower and wider curves,
that constant in the front always
guarantees that the area equals one.
The special case where Sigma equals one has
a specific name, we call it the Standard
Normal Distribution which plays an especially
important role for you and me in this lesson.
And all possible normal distributions are not
only parametrized with this value Sigma but we
also subtract off another constant, mu, from
the variable X and this essentially just lets
you slide the graph left and right so that you
can prescribe the mean of this distribution.
So, in short, we have two parameters; one
describing the mean, one describing the
standard deviation and they're all tied together
in this big formula involving an e and a pi.
Now that all of that is on the table, let's
look back again at the idea of starting
with some random variable and asking what the
distributions for sums of that variable look like.
As we've already gone over, when
you increase the size of that sum,
the resulting distribution will shift, according
to a growing mean and it slowly spreads out,
according to a growing standard deviation.
And putting some actual formulas to it,
if we know the mean of our underlying random
variable, and we call it mu, and we also know its
standard deviation, and we call it Sigma, then the
mean for the sum on the bottom will be mu times
the size of the sum and the standard deviation
will be Sigma times the square root of that size.
So now, if we want to claim that this looks more
and more like a bell curve, and a bell curve is
only described by two different parameters,
the mean and the standard deviation, you know
what to do. You could plug those two values into
the formula and it gives you a highly explicit,
albeit kind of complicated, formula for a
curve that should closely fit our distribution.
But there's another way we can
describe it that's a little more
elegant and lends itself to a very
fun visual that we can build up to.
Instead of focusing on the sum of all of these
random variables, let's modify this expression a
little bit where what we'll do is we'll look at
the mean that we expect that sum to take and we
subtract it off so that our new expression has
a mean of zero, and then we're going to look
at the standard deviation we expect of our
sum and divide out by that. Which basically
just rescales the units so that the standard
deviation of our expression will equal one. This
might seem like a more complicated expression,
but it actually has a highly readable meaning.
It's essentially saying 'how many standard
deviations away from the mean is this sum.'
For example, this bar here corresponds to
a certain value that you might find when
you roll 10 dice and you add them all up. And
it's position, a little above negative one, is
telling you that that value is a little bit less
than one standard deviation lower than the mean.
Also, by the way, in anticipation for the
animation I'm trying to build to here,
the way I'm representing things on that lower
plot is that the area of each one of these bars
is telling us the probability of the corresponding
value rather than the height. You might think of
the y-axis as representing not probability but a
kind of probability density. The reason for this
is to set the stage so that it aligns with the
way we interpret continuous distributions where
the probability of falling between a range
of values is equal to an area under a curve
between those values. In particular, the area
of all the bars together is going to be one.
Now, with all of that in place, let's
have a little fun. Let me start by rolling
things back so that the distribution on the
bottom represents a relatively small sum,
like adding together only three such
random variables. Notice what happens
as I change the distribution we start
with. As it changes, the distribution
on the bottom completely changes its shape.
It's very dependent on what we started with.
If we let the size of our sum get a little bit
bigger, say going up to 10, and as I change the
distribution for X, it largely stays looking like
a bell curve but I can find some distributions
that get it to change shape. For example,
the really lopsided one where almost all
the probability is in the numbers 1 or 6 results
in this kind of spiky bell curve. And if you'll
recall, earlier on, I actually showed this in the
form of a simulation. Though if you're wondering
whether that spikiness was an artifact of the
randomness or reflected the true distribution,
turns out it reflects the true distribution. In
this case, 10 is not a large enough sum for the
central limit theorem to kick in but if instead
I let that sum grow and I consider adding 50
different values, which is actually not that big,
then no matter how I change the distribution for
underlying random variable, it has essentially no
effect on the shape of the plot on the bottom. No
matter where we start, all of the information and
nuance for the distribution of X gets washed away
and we tend towards this single universal shape
described by a very elegant function for the
standard normal distribution 1 over square root
of 2 pi times e to the negative x squared over 2.
This, this right here is what the central
limit theorem is all about. Almost nothing
you can do to this initial distribution
changes the shape we tend towards.
Now, the more theoretically minded among
you might still be wondering what is the
actual theorem. Like, what's the mathematical
statement that could be proved or disproved
that we're claiming here. If you want a nice
formal statement, here's how it might go.
Consider this value where we're summing up
N different instantiations of our random
variable but tweaked and tuned so that its
mean and standard deviation are one. Again,
meaning you can read it as asking how many
standard deviations away from the mean is the sum.
Then the actual rigorous no jokes this time
statement of the central limit theorem is that
if you consider the probability that this value
falls between two given real numbers, a and b,
and you consider the limit of that probability
as the size of your sum goes to infinity,
then that limit is equal to a certain
integral, which basically describes
the area under a standard normal
distribution between those two values.
Again, there are three underlying assumptions
that I have yet to tell you, but other than those,
in all of its gory detail, this right
here is the central limit theorem.
All of that is a bit theoretical, so it might
be helpful to bring things back down to earth
and turn back to the concrete example
that I mentioned at the start where you
imagine rolling a die 100 times, and let's
assume it's a fair die for this example,
and you add together the results.
The challenge for you is to find a
range of values such that you're 95% sure
that the sum will fall within this range.
For questions like this, there's a handy rule
of thumb about normal distributions which is
that about 68% of your values are going to fall
within one standard deviation of the mean. 95% of
your values, the thing we care about, fall
within two standard deviations of the mean
and a whopping 99.7% of your values will fall
within three standard deviations of the mean.
It's a rule of thumb that's commonly memorized
by people who do a lot of probability and stats.
Naturally, this gives us what we need
for our example and let me go ahead and
draw out what this would look like where
I'll show the distribution for a fair die
up at the top and the distribution
for a sum of 100 such dice on the
bottom. Which by now as you know looks
like a certain normal distribution.
Step one with a problem like this is to find
the mean of your initial distribution. Which in
this case will look like 1/6 times 1 plus 1/6
times 2, on and on and on and works out to be
3.5. We also need the standard deviation
which requires calculating the variance,
which as you know involves adding all
the squares of the differences between
the values and the means and it works out to be
2.92. Square root of that comes out to be 1.71.
Those are the only two numbers we need and
I will invite you again to reflect on how
magical it is that those are the only
two numbers that you need to completely
understand the bottom distribution. Its mean
will be 100 times mu, which is 350 and its
standard deviation will be the square root
of 100 times Sigma. So, 10 times Sigma, 17.1.
Remembering our handy rule of thumb, we're looking
for values two standard deviations away from the
mean and when you subtract two Sigma from the
mean, you end up with about 316 and when you
add two Sigma, you end up with roughly 384.
And there you go... That gives us the answer.
Okay, I promise to wrap things up shortly,
but while we're on this example, there's one -
more question that's worth your time to ponder.
Instead of just asking about the sum of 100 die
rolls, let's say I had you divide that number by
100, which basically means all the numbers in
our diagram in the bottom get divided by 100.
Take a moment to interpret what
this all would be saying then.
The expression essentially tells you
the empirical average for 100 different
die rolls and that interval we found is now
telling you what range you are expecting to
see for that empirical average. In other words,
you might expect it to be around 3.5 - that's
the expected value for a die roll, but what's
much less obvious and what the central limit
theorem lets you compute is how close to that
expected value you'll reasonably find yourself.
In particular, it's worth your time
to take a moment mulling over what
the standard deviation for this empirical average
is and what happens to it as you look at
a bigger and bigger sample of die rolls.
Lastly, but probably most importantly, let's talk
about the assumptions that go into this theorem.
The first one is that all of these variables that
we're adding up are independent from each other.
The outcome of one process doesn't influence the
outcome of any other process. The second is that
all of these variables are drawn from the same
distribution. Both of these have been implicitly
assumed with our dice example. We've been treating
the outcome of each die roll as independent from
the outcome of all the others and we're assuming
that each die follows the same distribution.
Sometimes in the literature you'll see
these two assumptions lumped together
under the initials i.i.d for Independent
and identically distributed. One situation
where these assumptions are decidedly NOT
true would be the Galton board. I mean,
think about it - is it the case that the way a
ball bounces off of one of the pegs is independent
from how it's going to bounce off the next peg?
Absolutely not. Depending on the last bounce,
it's coming in with a completely different
trajectory. And is it the case that the
distribution of possible outcomes off of each peg
are the same for each peg that it hits? Again,
almost certainly not. Maybe it hits one peg
glancing to the left, meaning the outcomes are
hugely skewed in that direction and then
hits the next one glancing to the right.
When I made all those simplifying
assumptions in the opening example,
it wasn't just to make this easier to think
about. It's also that those assumptions were
necessary for this to actually be an
example of the central limit theorem.
Nevertheless, it seems to be true
that for the real Galton board,
despite violating both of these, a normal
distribution does kind of come about...
Part of the reason might be that there
are generalizations of the theorem beyond
the scope of this video that relax these
assumptions, especially the second one.
But I do want to caution you against the fact
that many times, people seem to assume that a
variable is normally distributed even when
there's no actual justification to do so.
The third assumption is actually fairly subtle.
It's that the variance we've been computing for
these variables is finite. This was never an issue
for the dice example because there were only six
possible outcomes, but in certain situations
where you have an infinite set of outcomes,
when you go to compute the variance, the
sum ends up diverging off to infinity.
These can be perfectly valid probability
distributions and they do come up in practice
but in those situations, as you consider adding
many different instantiations of that variable
and letting that sum approach infinity, even
if the first two assumptions hold, it is very
much a possibility that the thing you tender
towards is not actually a normal distribution.
If you've understood everything up to this point,
you now have a very strong foundation in what the
central limit theorem is all about. And next up,
I'd like to explain why it is that this
particular function is the thing that we
tend towards and why it has a pi in
it - what it has to do with circles.